good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-5140
containment class ketter
disruption class eki
and risk class critical
special containment procedures due to
the exorbitant cost and difficulty in
safely extracting scp-5140 instances
from mount everest mobile task force
delta 14
winter wonderland will periodically
ascend everest to bury any scp-5140
instances
in the snow campaigns are underway to
tighten restrictions for climbing
permits for mount everest
on both the nepalese and tibetan sides
description scp-5140
refers to a number of frozen corpses
scattered across mount everest located
in the himalayas
of tibet the number of scp-5140
instances
is unclear but is accepted to be over
100
and below 200 at the time of writing
scp-5140 instances are ecto-entropic
when physically exposed to heat of any
form including body heat
they will absorb it without raising
their temperature which rests at
approximately 10 degrees celsius
or 50 degrees fahrenheit this process
usually renders physical contact with
scp-5140 instances
fatal if an individual dies as a result
of contact with scp-5140 instances
their corpse will become another 5140
instance
addendum 5140.1
mission record november 12 2015.
status update approaching summit
encountered 34
bodies across chinese route buried all
provisions steady likely to reach summit
tomorrow
acknowledged continue
encounter a minor anomaly on instances
exceptionally low temperatures result in
muscle contraction postmortem
bodies curled up and frozen hard to pry
open before burial
might have to bury like that
acknowledged
the mission granted barry is convenient
approaching summit abnormally high
numbers of instances
encountered 19 since yesterday old
instances
getting unburied likely
strong winds blowing off snow very
deeper if possible
approached hillary step this morning
we'll ascend to summon in an hour or two
14 more bodies since last contact
team unnerved understandable
almost there now discovered lone body on
summit
attempted to bury shovel hits something
is stuck can't pull it out turned around
body was gone fell off the summit
don't know team has rattled please
advise
acknowledged sending out survey teams
attempting to see if something was seen
falling from summit
use a spare shovel if more bodies are
encountered orders are to descend from
chinese route
using already cleared paths godspeed
descended step patrick touched one
me and arnold buried him acknowledged
emergency attempted to descend chinese
route
discovered camp remains torn apart three
instances curled up intent
instances moving hurried descent
acknowledged get down safely we'll move
forward from there
personnel ready to receive you at camp
stay
safe mass of them blocking the path
one reached out from the ground grabbed
arnold
he's one of them i ran back can't go
down
can't go back up arnold was carrying
provisions
only have one can of oxygen left help
attempt to use flare gun to clear path
stay
at safe distance team is already on
route to extract
you stay calm minimize breathing
they're moving don't come to the summit
it's not safe the ground isn't safe
don't let climbers on everest the
mountain
is danger team is arriving in less than
two hours
hold steady a rescue detachment of
mobile task force delta 14
arrived at charlie smith's gps tracker
an hour and 36 minutes later
they cited no unburied scp-5140
instances on their approach
smith's body was discovered lacking the
signs typical of an scp-5140 instance
autopsy indicates he died from exposure
and suffocation
due to inadequate oxygen intake further
investigation
indicated his oxygen intake valve was
damaged
during the ascent to the summit bodies
of arnold hillary
and patrick edmund were discovered
higher up everest
hillary died from exposure while edmond
was found to be an scp-5140
instance it is currently believed that
smith's inadequate oxygen
led to him hallucinating scp-5140
instances
blocking their path and destroying their
campsite
hillary's foot was found wedged into a
rockfall likely the source
of his immobility this incident has been
taken into account
and supply manifests for future
expeditions adjusting
accordingly addendum
5140.2
file update april 25th 2024
location mount everest nepal
status concluded
time 1 49 p.m local time
april 25th 2024
disruption class kennick
event summary increased global
temperatures have resulted in
significant thawing of ice sheets
and snow drifts on everest such thawing
caused a large avalanche
at 11 49 am local time which moved a
large amount of snow
off the summit lower depth of snow
allowed scanning planes to identify
significant amount of scp-5140 instances
below the snow further excavation
revealed scp-5140 instances
form a significant portion of everest
itself
currently it is estimated 45 percent
of mount everest's mass is formed by
corpses
i would like to give a special thank you
to
brian b razzle brown it's not a spoon
corey barker arbiter soul
the morrigan retalias
matthew gilmore drew peacock
fana matakik victoria clarkson
eric corbich kawaii fire keeper
mr dutchak joker corvus
king madding bryson
samurai corgis james
saba nj vujak
and justin day if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos
and some other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the thank you
you